the most comfortable men's boxers and
t-shirts you'll ever find are at leisure
of NYC their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers
feel as light as air and their silky
smooth supima cotton crewneck t-shirts
are amazing I love them you'll get 15
off with code Pacman at davidpackman.com
NYC
let's start today with the topic of
protests many of you have been writing
to me and in different versions asking
do I think there are going to be violent
protests or even riots if and when
Donald Trump is indicted arrested
surrenders arraigned whatever the case
may be increasingly it seems as though
that is going to be sometime over the
next seven days if at all I am I'm
couching all of these things with if at
all so I won't say it every time but
that's the speculation right now and
Donald Trump called for protests in some
of those original truth social posts
that first started this entire
conversation about the arrest Donald
Trump putting protest protest protest
it's time on and on and on and of course
we're a well positioned to be concerned
it's reasonable to be concerned about
violent protests from Maga because
violent protests from Maga are in a way
how we got into this mess in the first
place with what happened on January 6th
of 2021 but
there's a difference the early signals
are that it's really not clear the Maga
people are willing to go out and do the
protesting in this particular case
partially this was evidenced by Monday
evenings completely flaccid pathetic
rally just an impotent rally in lower
Manhattan where like there were more
media people than protesters and there
were maybe a couple dozen protesters we
also had that video from Trump Tower
yesterday where five people were there
holding signs saying Trump one and one
person blew a shofar it's not exactly an
electric atmosphere of protesting and
defense of Donald Trump right now well
Republican senator Lindsey Graham
appeared on Fox and Friends yesterday
and he's using language that raised the
eyebrows of many
and the language he's using is that if
Trump is indicted it will blow up our
country and again many of you taking
this is a sign that he's leading
protesters to maybe behave violently
violently let's listen to what Lindsay
had to say
so are you concerned about the uh
district attorney Bragg Alvin Bragg
indicting president Trump next week in
an unprecedented way and the circus it
would be around that it's going to blow
up our country and this is a bunch of BS
you've had the prosecutor before brag Mr
Vance look at the case and pass on it
you had the U.S attorney in New York say
I'm not going to do it federally there
was an intervening cause other than
Trump running one of the guys in the
DA's office wrote a book very critical
events you should have prosecuted Trump
you let him off and Bragg feels that
pressure he's a George Soros back
prosecutor okay so Lindsay is on topic
with all of the bullet points but that
first line if Trump is indicted it will
blow up our country some are
understanding to be an allusion to
violence that Lindsay is saying go out
there and do the violent stuff now I'll
be very honest with you I find Lindsey
Graham to be a completely deplorable
two-faced individual
he for years now has bounced like a
pinball between playing the rational
Republican who can step back from Maga
insanity and tell things the way they
are sort of like pretending to be Mitt
Romney in a way but then he will behave
uh in ways reminiscent of someone who
should be evaluated psychiatrically for
example his unhinged rant during the
Brett Kavanaugh confirmation hearings
where Lindsay got all red in the face
screaming at the top of his lungs about
how no one has been treated more poorly
and unfairly and unjustly than Brett
Kavanaugh so there are two Lindsey
Grahams Lindsey Graham has no qualms
morally with subtly inciting violence in
the event that Trump is arrested but I
think what the wrench in this is going
to be
is that the Trump people don't really
seem to care enough to actually go out
and protest now this may change if and
when Trump is arrested but in other
times I would have said this is very
dangerous this is a Tinder Box that's
about to explode but right now I'm not
really seeing the evidence of that I'm
not seeing the rage and the engagement
on the ground that these right Wingers
insist is actually out there ready to
come out in defense of trump and again
case in point just look at the turnout
for the protest on Monday which we
covered in lower Manhattan more media
than protesters and even our friend
Jason Selvig from the good liars getting
multiple minutes of being interviewed by
right side broadcasting because they
didn't really have real protesters that
could coherently speak so normally I
would say this is extraordinarily
dangerous now I say people like Lindsey
Graham are dangerous hopefully they're
being dangerous in an environment that
is not actually going to lead to
violence that's the Hope let's now look
at another example of one of these
so-called protests
this is so funny
Donald Trump has been calling for
protests for days on the basis of his
allegedly imminent arrest and indictment
Trump has been saying protest protest
protest it is time it is time it is time
to take the country back Etc well
protesters did show up yesterday outside
of Trump Tower except they were
protesting in favor of trump getting
arrested
it's just so funny Trump's screaming to
anyone that will listen you've got to go
in protest you've got to go and protest
there were protesters but they had a
sign saying Trump is guilty no one is
above the law seditious conspiracy lock
Trump up Etc take a look at this take a
listen uh not exactly the protest Trump
was looking for interestingly enough we
bring you this live shot here we know
the former president has called for for
protests in a peaceful manner many
Republicans push back on that but
interestingly enough it's the opposite
side that's outside protesting now
saying Insurrection Tick Tock time's up
no one is about the law Trump is guilty
sir the protesters are here fantastic
what do the signs say Sir they say to
lock you up and many supporting the
possible indictment of former president
Trump there again what does science
really looked like they were made by the
Grassroots various Roots groups too
don't they Sean yeah we'll continue to
follow that again and so the this is a
report from Newsmax by the way the guest
here suggesting the signs that are being
held up are two professionally made
to really be actual activist Grassroots
sign clearly there's someone behind it
and usually the someone is George Soros
I mean you have to understand the
language that's a dog whistle if I've
ever seen one not exactly the protest
that Donald Trump was looking more for
one more thing on protests a group did
Gather in Florida yesterday outside of
Mar-A-Lago and this was in in West Palm
Beach this is really funny MSNBC
interviewed a trump supporter who was at
the protest and she says we are not
protesting we're not and by the way if
Trump's indicted we're not going to do
anything seemingly wanting to preempt
any possibility of trumpists being
accused of violence it's she she seems
not to be liking this narrative
introduce you real fast to one woman who
we met Debbie you were telling me that
you helped promote this online what type
of folks have you done this before have
you how did you
remain
and get it out to some and they get it
out to some and that's just how it gets
around when you saw Donald Trump call
for protest what did that mean to you
protest we're not protesting we're
supporting the president no protests and
if he were to be indicted what should
the response be from supporters like you
that's the best what if so what would
people like you do nothing we would
celebrate the arrest
what type of folks are here today
every day normal everyday hard-working
people there you go obviously very
hard-working enough to be out
protesting at 109 pm on a Tuesday as we
know that's notoriously a time when
hard-working people are able to go and
just hold flags for a guy who lost a
recent election and simply can't accept
that so this is going to be super
interesting but I maintain right now
when I take the temperature of Maga
um I don't get the definitive feeling
that they're ready to go and Riot if and
when Trump is arrested and I think
that's a good thing you know a lot of
right-wingers write in all the time and
they say David you want in order to get
ratings and clicks you want there to be
violence and that will allow you to go
after Trump supporters as being violent
and that's you it's terrible that you
want that no no no I don't want that I
don't want that at all and in fact if
you go back to the January 6 2021 Trump
trump live stream that we did uh you see
that I don't exactly look thrilled when
they breach the capital and break in uh
despite the fact that it did generate a
lot of attention I would rather what's
better for the country which is for
there not to be violent outbursts as a
result of the justice system carrying
forward and indicting when there is
evidence to do so that's not an action
that I want to see there be violence in
response to so of course we will be
watching it latest rumor is maybe
indictment today but Trump surrender
next week or maybe nothing will happen
we really don't know but as soon as I
know anything you will as well make sure
you're subscribed to the David Pacman
Show YouTube channel at youtube.com
slash the David Pacman show we have a
packed program for you today and I'm
glad you're here
one of our sponsors today is Leisure of
NYC offering Ultra comfortable fair
trade men's clothing at fair prices guys
know it can be very tough to find good
boxers and t-shirts the search is over
because all boxer briefs by Leisure of
NYC are made with amazingly soft
moisture wicking viscose from bamboo
super lightweight like air but it
doesn't Bunch up and it's also great for
the planet Leisure of NYC also makes
really great supima cotton crew neck
t-shirts less than one percent of men's
Basics today are made with supima cotton
it is the best out there it feels like
Silk quite frankly you can walk around
in a scratchy t-shirt all day or you can
enjoy the cloud soft feel of supima
cotton and actually love the shirt
you're wearing these are my go-to
t-shirts and boxers nothing else even
comes close to providing this level of
comfort and all of their products are
fair to trade and made sustainably go
pick up the most comfortable t-shirts
and boxers you will ever own but hurry
because they often sell out especially
the boxers go to davidpackman.com
NYC and you will get 15 off with the
code Pacman at checkout and the link is
down below
to all of our new viewers and listeners
this week and there are many of you the
David packman show is an audience
supported program I invite you to add
your name to our list of supporters by
signing up at joinpakman.com you get a
whole bunch of great benefits including
an extra show every single day just for
you during which we discuss more stories
producer Pat Ford joins me on the bonus
show you also get commercial free daily
video and audio streams of the show
maybe you prefer the audio podcast maybe
you prefer the video either way all
commercials stripped out of it and you
get invited to the members only Town
Halls you get a members only sound board
behind the paywall and a lot of other
great things you can sign up at
joinpakman.com and of course the coupon
code 24 starts now is always available
for a limited time you can also use the
coupon code indict I don't think I have
to explain that one to you the code in
diet saves you a bundle of cash at
joinpakman.com all right let's run
through the latest over the last 24
hours related to this potentially
looming arrest a failed former president
Donald Trump starting with there is a
stunning new report from New York Times
reporters Maggie Haberman and Michael C
Bender that Donald Trump is completely
disconnected from reality wants to be
handcuffed if he is arrested and seems
to see most of this as no big deal and
something that will just Galvanize his
supporters in favor of him to which to
some degree I think is true and I will
get to it but the people around Trump
are telling the New York Times
Trump genuinely doesn't seem to
understand the legal Jeopardy that he's
in here because it's not only one it's
not only two he is looking at
potentially three or more arrests and
indictments over the next couple of
months the New York Times article
trumpet Mar-A-Lago magical thinking and
a perp walk fixation those who have
spent time with Donald Trump in recent
days say he has often appeared
significantly disconnected from the
severity of his potential legal woes
behind closed doors Trump has told
friends and Associates he welcomes the
idea of being paraded by the authorities
before a throng of reporters and news
cameras he has even mused openly about
whether he should smile for the
assembled media and he has pondered how
the public would react and is said to
have described the potential spectacle
as a fun experience no one is quite sure
whether his remarks are bravado or
Genuine resignation about what lies
ahead if he is truly looking forward to
it he may be disappointed and part of
that disappointment is this paragraph
indicates is that even though often that
perp walk handcuffed situation happens
where law enforcement walks You by a
throng of reporters and they take
pictures of you in handcuffs with
someone like Trump you would expect that
it's quite plausible that secret service
would arrange with the court to do it in
a quieter and different way but I have
to tell you that this is very much a
reflection of Trump's narcissism there's
also a guardian article level that
explains Trump wants to be handcuffed
for his court appearance in the Stormy
Daniels case people close to the former
president said to be unsure whether he's
serious about wanting to do a perp walk
but he wants to be handcuffed he thinks
that that would turn things into a
spectacle and that that would be a
really really great thing a very common
narcissistic tendency as we've
illuminated and enumerated for you
before
narcissists tend to think that they're
always smart enough
clever enough smooth enough to escape
consequences for their wrongdoing so
when try it if indeed Trump is the
narcissist that we and many believe him
to be
and we remember other elements of this
remember during the Mueller probe he
wanted to sit down and testify uh even
though
um every single lawyer who got anywhere
near him said you absolutely do not want
to do that lawyers realizing that Trump
would just lie and lie and lie because
another trait of narcissists is they're
not going to be able to tell that I'm
lying they're not going to be able to
catch me in a lie so given that we know
that about Trump
he may realistically be seeing this
entire series of possible arrests and
indictments against him almost like as a
TV show almost like as an out of Body
Experience where it's kind of happening
to something else he's just playing a
character in the entire thing but he's
in control and he's always going to come
out on top now I do think he is going to
come out on top in the sense of
I do believe
that if there is one arrest and it's the
Stormy Daniels case and it's the weakest
of all the possible cases at least in
the Republican primary it will help
Trump
in the general election if Trump is the
nominee I believe the arrests are not
going to help Trump the Maga crowd and
many of Trump's more hardcore Ardent
supporters certainly will be galvanized
by what they will see as an unfair
politically motivated arrest if it
happens so in the primary I think Trump
will benefit from it but I think it's
going to hurt him in the general if
indeed he is the nominee and Trump again
because he's a narcissist
he has this idea that he'll always spin
it in his favor and what sources are
saying is he doesn't really have any
idea how serious all of this could be
how expensive all of this could be and
how damaging it actually could be in a
hypothetical general election where
Trump is the Republican domini in 2024.
this is not stopping Trump from
continuing to send bizarre lawyers on TV
and that's what I want to look at next
we looked over the last week at an
incredible viral interview where Trump
lawyer Joe takapina went on MSNBC and
was interviewed by Ari melber and lunged
for papers tried to Lunge and take
papers from Ari melber's hand another
Trump lawyer has gone on MSNBC and it
went just as poorly if not worse instant
collapse from Drew findling Drew
findling is a criminal defense attorney
he's really known like as a hip-hop
attorney because he has represented a
number of well-known hip-hop musicians
doesn't make him any better or worse of
an attorney just it's an interesting
thing that Trump has gone with someone
who is known really as as a hip-hop
attorney
um he went on MSNBC Ari melber asked him
questions it really doesn't go well for
findling take a look at this same level
of passion but you're not the judge or
the jury in this case you're the lawyer
we're talking to you not for your
conclusions without evidence but for the
evidence you can Marshal right now I'm
giving you the time if you can't do it
tonight if you can't give us any
arguments then we will note that but let
me put up on the screen again for your
rebuttal if you want to take this time
and importantly I should mention this is
a defense attorney for Trump in the
Georgia case which I believe is
potentially the strongest one uh
election fraud in Georgia if you request
or attempt to cause another person to
engage in voter fraud that's criminal
solicitation if you conspire or agree
with another to commit a violation that
is another Georgia statute those are
both felonies those are just two and
there are as you know others Donald
Trump post December 14th I'll give you
the widest possible birth that before
it's certified there are arguments that
could be theoretically made about
alternate electors but post December
14th he's on tape doing it we have a new
call we learned about in the last week
demanding it how is that not soliciting
or conspiring fraud
yeah so so our I'm familiar my team is
familiar with all those statutes and
while I'm looking at this you know
camera I could tell you we're incredibly
familiar with those statues they aren't
new to us we do a lot of political cases
sure we are absolutely confident having
looked at the evidence that our client
has not violated any of those we're not
going to look at it two-dimensionally
we're going to look at a
three-dimensional
and he's completely Innocent but what
did he mean when he said find votes that
don't exist after certification what
could that possibly mean other than find
votes that don't exist
well I will say this and that is that
again okay
looking at the entire
62 minutes putting it all in context
there was nothing illegal said by our
client Ah that's the best when Trump
said I need 11
000 votes give me a break I just want to
find 11
780 votes which is one more than we have
what did he mean when he said that well
you've got to listen to the whole call
in context oh really did he open the
call with everything I'm about to say is
merely a joke what what could have
preceded that that would have made that
in any way not a violation of those
statutes and this continued and
melbridge is doing everything he can to
try to actually get substance from Drew
findling did he lost the election and
got people to submit false material to
the government and everywhere else or
conspire to do so and that's a potential
crime all right so so Ari let me tell
you because what I'm not going to do is
I'm not going to be a hypocrite and I'm
not going to be disingenuous oh good
well then I'm sure he's gonna that's a
nice disclaimer when I talk about
prosecutors who I know very very well
okay and and have great relationships
with but when I call and say and file
something that they that they went down
the political Avenue and that has no
place in this case I'm not going to turn
around and start being political because
then so understand that this is a case
where the fact this is a classic
particularly for lawyers on TV where
you're not you're not trying the case on
TV at least not overtly
um if if the facts aren't on your side
you argue about process it was political
and it was the wrong venue and it was
all targeting my client unfairly and
blah blah blah I'm a hypocrite for
everything that I put in 50 pages so
respectfully I appreciate you bringing
that up and I appreciate it you
appreciate it I do appreciate being on
the show but I got to tell you drew but
I'm not going political I gotta tell you
because I'm not going I'm giving you
time and I'll give your colleagues time
and we'll have you back but it is not
accurate absolutely but this is a case
about out trying to steal an election
ascertaining the facts of that is not
quote unquote political it is the
bleeding the Beating Heart of the center
of this case because Donald Trump lied
about it and it seems today that you're
in a you have an inability to
acknowledge that he lost the state of
Georgia which is odd because you know he
lost the state of Georgia we all know
that
I I don't have an inability to do
anything I have the ability to tell you
what I think was in the scope of the
questions that I'll answer regarding the
filing of 50 pages motion and 400 pages
of exhibits and we've got concerns I
think you'd agree we call it a special
purpose grand jury nothing right
understood and but nothing in that
is political from our vantage point in
fact he's not going to do anything
political at all in terms of answering
inconvenient questions but then when
they stuff this filing full of 400 pages
of quote concerns that are riddled with
political concerns that's not political
according to him if you're having
trouble following this I don't blame you
for being political so I'm not going to
be disingenuous and start being
political I'm going to talk about the
facts that are contained in there yeah
right and I'm not going to be put in a
position where I have to make one claim
or another claim
um I am as you know you pointed out my
relationship to the bar deeply committed
to my profession and deeply committed
all right yeah so now he's saying he
really is committed to being a lawyer
wow you know I thought that Trump would
I really thought they had Trump dead to
rights by the way the look on Ari
melber's face here in this still shot
kind of says everything says it says it
all
um I I Trump seems like he's super
guilty he seems guilty as hell but did
you know his lawyer is really committed
to the practice of law oh he is oh well
then it must be not guilty I guess this
is a nonsense interview and I don't
really even know whether so I guess
MSNBC wants to do these interviews
because they sort of always go like this
and it's very cartoonish I guess the
lawyers want to do the interviews
because they know probably that Trump
doesn't always pay his lawyers and so if
they can get some publicity out of it
then maybe they can make money on the
back end from other people hiring them I
don't really know but they come together
and it just instantly implodes and so
the continued interviews with Trump
Trump's lawyers not going particularly
well and then closing out our review of
the last 24 hours it also not going
particularly well for Donald Trump
I have to mention
that in his latest tirade in which he
goes full conspiracy
Donald Trump now doesn't even look
orange
it's like burnt sienna for those who
used to watch Bob Ross I can only
describe this as the color of a sunset
very late in the evening I don't know
why Trump is doing this to himself but
he is now
uh a bizarre color
and he is raising the Deep state in his
latest full conspiracy rant
Trump is now announcing if indeed he
becomes the next president of the United
States he will create a truth commission
this now does sound like 1984. you know
for for so long now I've been saying
everybody says this is orwellian It's
really hoxland this is really more out
of Brave New World than it is out of
1984.
the truth commission Trump wants is more
orwellian here's Trump's latest promise
uh
I I don't know folks this is scary stuff
to expose the hoaxes and abuses of power
that have been tearing our country apart
we will establish a Truth and
Reconciliation Commission wow to
declassify and publish all documents on
deep State spying censorship and
Corruption and there are plenty of them
right fifth we will launch a major
Crackdown on government leakers who
collude with the fake news to
deliberately we false narratives Now
understand that's a Crackdown on
whistleblowers Trump calls them false
leakers but in many of these cases we're
talking about whistleblowers and Trump
clearly wants to go after not only the
Whistleblower but the media Outlets that
publish the stuff as well the
journalists as well completely attacking
overtly journalism as an institution to
subvert our government and our democracy
when possible we will press criminal
charges there you go as many as one
hundred thousand government positions
could be moved out and I mean
immediately of Washington to places
filled with Patriots who love America
and yeah
um so first of all it's like sure sure
you're gonna do that right after your
new health care plan and Mexico is going
to pay for it as well right so so of
course with all of these things it's
less about what Trump will do but what
Trump would like to do or is willing to
admit that he would try to do this would
be endlessly chilling so corrosive to
many of the fundamental institutions of
American democracy and in a sense it's
the same old song and dance this is the
real grievance politics when we've
talked before the right says the left
wants to censor it's the right that's
doing a lot of censoring the right says
the left is going to try to steal an
election well the right tried to steal
steal the election and of course the
Wright loves to say the left is all
about grievances grievances over racism
and grievances over this that the other
thing the right is running at this point
the height the epitome of grievance
politics but it's based on grievances
that are imaginary completely imaginary
grievances so Trump looks to absolutely
terrible he sounds terrible he is now
regularly releasing these videos often
at midnight or even later they don't
make any sense they're scary and if
you're wondering like why is Trump doing
this stuff when it seems like he's about
to get arrested the New York Times
article we talked about earlier says
that Trump's totally disconnected from
the reality of his legal problems Trump
seems to think that it's all going to be
great he wants to be handcuffed he
thinks it's going to be great for his
campaign and that he's going to win and
then he's going to put in place a truth
commission would be really scary if he
were likely to be able to do it but it's
up to us to make sure that he's not able
to that clip I just played and others
from today you can find them on our
Instagram you can find them on our
YouTube channel you'll be able to find
them on our Tick Tock or or anywhere
else that we publish content
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
it's great to be joined today by Matt
Gertz senior fellow at Media Matters
where his work focuses on the fox Trump
feedback loop news coverage of Politics
as well as media ethics Matt really
great to have you on I appreciate it
good to be here so I mean let's just
start with something uh and maybe that
can be the Dominion lawsuit against Fox
News we have of course been covering
with great interest for me one of the
most interesting story lines has been
yet another layer to what goes out on
the airwaves at Fox doesn't necessarily
match what the feelings are among some
of the hosts behind the scenes and
that's totally fine but what's the
bigger story if there is one yet about
how the audience of Fox News is reacting
to this lawsuit and the leaked texts if
they are even aware of it because this
is something I've been talking to my
audience about will will the average Fox
newer Fox News viewer even know what it
is that is going on yeah I think you've
hit the nail on the head there that's
really the question I mean as we know uh
people who follow Fox News are really in
a bubble of right-wing media they are
getting their news solely from uh
Outlets like Fox uh they are disinclined
to believe what they hear from uh people
like you and me and the New York Times
And The Washington Post and everybody
else and that's something that fox has
really cultivated for decades uh trying
to make its viewers uh not believe other
sources
um I think what we are seeing though is
uh some right wing Outlets are trying to
get the news out in hopes of building up
their own audiences that internal
rivalry within the right
um
could be causing Fox some trouble as
Outlets like Newsmax try to Hive off a
little bit of Fox's market share by
revealing what fox uh hosts and
Executives were saying behind the scenes
we know that Donald Trump has been
arguing that now Fox News isn't doing as
well in the ratings he would argue
because they are no longer as positive
about him as they once were and we'll
get to the narrative about Trump on Fox
more recently but as far as the ratings
go is there any truth to that claim that
fox is not doing as well
I mean I I don't think uh specifically
uh it's easy to make that claim right
now I mean in general there's been a
drop off uh in uh cable news viewership
since the last election right um I would
expect that to uh pop up a little bit
more as we get closer to the next
presidential election
um but uh right now I I don't think
we're seeing a an evaporation of uh
Fox's market share due to uh it not
supporting Trump enough though as we saw
in the Dominion filings they are very
very attuned uh to uh that possibility
and are willing to take fairly
substantial action uh in order to
prevent that from coming to pass so
there's a survey which suggests that
about a fifth of Fox News viewers now
say they trust the network less since
the revelations from the text messages
this is this is pretty squishy it
doesn't say strike me as the most
scientific claim and there's some
definitional questions here and how much
did they trust them before they probably
still trust Fox way more than you or I
would so there's sort of some
squishiness here but if we can believe
that there is a portion of the fox
audience that is now less less trusting
of Fox News What specifically would it
be would it be that they feel the hosts
are telling me one thing but privately
believe something else or like what
would be the Practical belief that's
affecting them yeah that's the real
question and something that the poll
can't really get to
um is is why they trust Fox less is it
because
um you know they think Fox was lying to
them on TV or that they think Fox uh was
not sufficiently supportive privately
like is is it because Fox uh is uh two
into election denial or not into it
enough uh is something we can't really
parse out of that poll
um though I mean I I do think to a large
extent uh what fox Spears the most is uh
other rivals on the right and so uh you
know it is bad for them if uh Newsmax or
oan can make the case that they are the
real pro-trump pro-election denial uh
Outlet uh and uh Fox's audience you know
turns to them instead what is the
landscape by the way right now of what
we would consider the biggest
competitors to to Fox and the the
context in which I ask that is one in
which many of us in this business we
know about Newsmax Newsmax has chosen to
stream live 24 7 I believe on YouTube
they're also on a number of Cable
Systems oan famously has had issues
where I think they've been they've been
non-renewed by DirecTV and and maybe one
other I I don't think you oan is
currently on YouTube and that may be
because they were kicked off although
the details sort of escaped me at this
point what what does like the
competitive landscape look like right
now yeah that's definitely definitely an
issue I mean I I think you know the TV
uh landscape is uh I think less robust
if anything than it was uh during the
2020 election cycle you had both Newsmax
and oan as as you mentioned uh losing
access to some cable uh systems being a
generally less available to the public
um at the same time as the TV audience
deteriorates some of the digital and
streaming options have gotten uh
Stronger so you see Outlets like uh the
daily wire or the blaze picking up some
steam uh and you know those are
competing for the same audience if not
uh you know showing up in the Nielsen
ratings or what have you and what's the
deal with real America's voice I see
Clips very often but it's not clear to
me whether it does that even have a
cable channel that is available aside
from whether anyone's carrying it or is
it online only it's mainly online I
think there's some cable availability
but not a ton
um that said you know as cord cutting
continues to uh you know be a real
business imperative uh for these
networks streaming does become somewhat
more viable and important so let's shift
a little now and talk about the primary
coverage that we've seen of the
Republican primary my assessment right
now and you'll be able to give us some
kind of more fine-tuned assessment was
that before the news of the looming
arrest of Donald Trump it seemed as
though Fox News was sort of creating a
little bit of space for themselves in
the direction of Ron DeSantis there were
some you know men on the street AKA
Brian kilmead in a diner segments that
seem tailored to find people that that
wanted Ron DeSantis to run they did some
actual man on the street segments where
like seven of the eight people they
included in the segment said they want
DeSantis their Steve Ducey has been
sporadically a little bit more critical
of Donald Trump and it sort of seemed
like it was a soft escape hatch so if
it's DeSantis they have a credible path
to have access but if it's Trump they
can kind of revert back and maintain the
access that they want we were talking
before the interview you said that that
may have shifted back a little bit since
the news of the looming arrest of trump
yeah I think what we tend to see with
Fox and Trump is they often have these
sorts of squabbles where uh the network
will try to create a little bit of
distance Trump will lash out at the
network for not being supportive enough
but in the end they always come back to
one another because their uh
relationship is so valuable to both of
them because Fox is a very effective
propaganda tool for Trump uh and Trump
has a real Hammer lock on the fox
viewership
um and so when we had uh we had a
similar sort of sense that fox and the
broader Murdoch Universe were trying to
break away last year uh but then the FBI
raid on Mar-A-Lago really sent the fox
hosts back into Trump's corner and news
that uh an indictment may be pending for
uh Donald Trump has created a similar
situation you have Fox hosts like uh
Sean Hannity and Tucker Carlson really
rallying around the former president
saying that any indictment of him is an
attack on
his supporters which obviously means
their viewers
um that it would be you know Un-American
and a sign that we're in a Banana
Republic so uh you know they're
certainly not uh planning on using any
indictment as a way to bolster some
other candidate in his stead
um it really seems like they've fully uh
committed back to his side right now how
should we expect the primary to go
assuming Trump stays in it and that the
arrests slash indictments don't don't
lead to him dropping out if there is a
real contested primary here should we
expect some version of what we've been
seeing throughout until it becomes clear
who is likely to be the nominee or since
Donald Trump continues to pull so
strongly at this point in time is it
likely that there will be some kind of
of shift I I'm trying to think of what
what we should expect as far as that
goes yeah I mean Trump's polling has
strengthened considerably since late
last year when it really looked like
DeSantis was making a run and you could
see uh the possibility that there would
be a sort of coalescing around him uh
but if that doesn't really happen if
DeSantis Fades and it's you know Trump
with 50 to 60 percent in the polls
against a bunch of people with you know
10 or less uh it's really hard to
imagine uh the various uh tentacles of
of the right wing not uh coming back
under his his wing I mean he's going to
have so much of the energy uh at that
point that it will become a sort of
business imperative for them uh like it
was after he became the nominee in 2016
team to find a way to be on his side
what do you make of the potential impact
of the Dominion suit because from a
business standpoint there's some pieces
that argue yeah it's quite possible that
Rupert Murdoch's gonna have to cut a
pretty large check but he can do that
and it won't really have an impact on
the network maybe there will be part of
an agreement could be this is all
hypothetical that some number of
Corrections need to be issued on air or
something like that we've seen that in
other situation situations but maybe not
do you think that the actual outcome
aside from the fact that the texts were
released and now we know what's in them
will impact Fox news's viewership one
way or the other
uh I don't know about its viewership I
do think that on the business side
things could get very dicey if Rupert
Murdoch has to cut a very large check
over this there's going to be uh I think
a substantial push uh from other
shareholders to sue the network uh for
you know various uh malfeasance uh cases
I I think that's gonna pose a real
problem uh for uh Murdoch going forward
um assuming that he does have to write
that check and you know that's always uh
it's sort of tricky to make predictions
around defamation lawsuits uh though
obviously this does seem uh pretty
strong as they go when it comes to just
more generally coverage of the Biden
Administration
it seems almost like there are enclaves
on Fox News where you see the sort of
more conspiratorial elements of it which
seem to be the nighttime shows Sean
Hannity Laura Ingram a lot more Hunter
Biden talk and and sort of this sort of
thing daytime I see a lot more sort of
what I would call contrived
controversies that when you look at the
story you and I probably go why is that
even a story but it's like minor things
about Joe Biden or Kamala Harris did or
didn't say or go to a particular place
and they should have it seems sort of
more that style of criticism of Biden
during the daytime news is my perception
of that split accurate what do we expect
the coverage of Biden to look like over
the next couple of years I I think what
we've run into at this point is that the
interest on the right for any sort of
policy discussion has really just fallen
off of a cliff yes I mean looking back
at what Fox was like in 2009 or 2010 you
had uh the sort of uh tea party uh push
for lower spending lower taxes and so on
and so forth uh and that kind of
discussion of domestic policy just
doesn't happen anymore instead it's been
replaced with uh various you know
controversies about woke public schools
and and these kind of very minor uh very
specific uh events that they can dig up
from local news and fit into their
broader narratives
um and so that's that's really what I
expect to see more of in the next couple
of years I think they're very bored with
Joe Biden and the Biden Administration
that they have not really bothered to
create much of a narrative against him
uh and that that is going to have a very
particular impact on the Republican
presidential primary because if they
don't need to talk about major Economic
Policy issues they're just not going to
yeah there's been sort of an air of like
Yeah Yeah Joe Biden's old and he's woke
and he's confused and Hunter Biden is
probably a problem but did you see what
happened at this drag show in Tulsa
Oklahoma or something like that and that
actually does seem to be far more
interesting to their viewers at this
point
yeah and it's the sort of thing where
they've trained their viewers to want a
very particular thing from the news uh
and now that's all the viewers want
um it's frankly it's pretty bad for the
Republican party that this is the case
because it's leading them to be like
just completely unable to discuss uh
issues that the broad scope of the
American populist wants to know about
yeah it's an opportunity for Biden if he
can get news of what he is doing to
these folks but you know yesterday on my
show we talked about the money being
released for the 30 a month Broadband
credits as well as adding some drugs to
the Medicare Part B inflation indexing
list like this is really tangible good
stuff that hits people's pocketbooks but
you're not going to hear about it if
you're a primary Fox News viewer and so
I guess that becomes the question mark I
think it's less of an issue about
reaching those uh Fox viewers than it is
that the message that Republicans are
going to make to the uh overall uh body
of Voters is going to be
incomprehensible to them because it is
so finely attuned for Fox viewers they
just don't have anything to say about uh
the the broad scope of domestic policy
that's super interesting we're going to
be watching that very closely we've been
speaking with Matt Gertz who's a senior
fellow at Media Matters Matt really
appreciate your time and your insights
today great to be here
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show you know I
love keeping you abreast of different
scams and there has been no greater scam
in the covet era than this urine drinker
urine injector urine nebulizer
Christopher key the if the name rings a
bell you may remember that we covered
this guy anti-vaxx leader urges
followers to drink their own urine to
fight covid
um that is not actually recommended
medically you should not drink your own
urine to fight covid anyway he now says
he invented a hologram sticker where he
stores information and it has something
to do with an energy field and it can
relieve pain if you put it in the right
spot now here's my question about this
who is stupid enough to fall for this
stuff
and I know that it's very easy to say
if you're dumb enough to fall for this
then you deserve it right a fool in
their money are soon parted or whatever
the case may be
but it's hard for me to believe anyone
with normal cognitive function would
fall for this so then I start to wonder
are the only people that fall for this
those who are cognitively limited and
actually do need to be protected from
charlatans like this I don't know let's
think about that as we listen to what
this guy explained and I will send you
these paint chips out anywhere in the
world and brother I love it when it
doesn't work for somebody because then I
want to go back to the try to figure out
why
I got you know the Hologram we were able
to store information into the Hologram
and then we put in the energy field it
resonates and when I took this to my
professors at Alabama many years ago and
they did the clinical study odds they're
like Christopher how in the world is
this doing this it's nothing but a
sticker guys it's not just a sticker it
is energy it is frequency everything is
frequency everything is everything okay
so
I can't imagine there's a single person
in what I call my core audience like I
get that there are people who hate watch
from all walks of life okay but the
people in my core audience people who
like subscribe to the audio podcast and
you know not met me maybe not every
episode but like three times a week you
listen to the show when you're at the
gym or whatever the case may be I can't
imagine there's a single person in my
audience that would fall for this and
our audience at this point is sizable
where are the people that fall for this
are they of normal cognitive function
and if the answer is no then isn't what
this guy is doing particularly
disgusting and particularly predatory
and of course I have the same questions
that often come up if he mentions God if
God made you a little different then we
just have to tweak the sticker to get it
to do the thing why wouldn't God just
prevent you from needing the sticker in
the first place why wouldn't God just
cure your pain why isn't prayer enough
why do you need this guy's sticker with
the energy field in whatever the case
may be now when I look at the sticker I
I can tell you why the sticker won't
work it doesn't have liquid silver in it
of course
that's a joke but that's the the main
question I bring to you
is who would actually fall for this I
don't I know a lot of people who don't
have formal education I know a lot of
people that I don't consider to be the
smartest people none of them would fall
for something like this or the urine
drinking who are the people that would
how many of them are there and quite
frankly do they need to be protected
from charlatans like this
Speaker of the House Kevin McCarthy has
been asked to weigh in about the looming
charges against the failed former
president Donald Trump
and when he was given the opportunity to
weigh in
he mentioned Hillary Clinton I know it
seems It seems impossible they're not
it's not they're not doing it again are
they yes Kevin McCarthy brought up
Hillary Clinton I'm almost ready to
declare that Hillary Clinton must pay
for the crimes of Donald Trump why not
right hold her accountable here is the
Speaker of the House
about the investigation that you're
creating committee challenge
yesterday into the prosecutor from New
York you guys have raised a lot of
concerns about the prosecutor but what
about the actual allegations here that
the former president may have falsified
this is Manu Raju from CNN by the way
records to cover for hush money payments
to cover up this alleged affair with an
adult film actress do you have any
concerns about that look the thing I
think about
um
it was interesting someone someone brief
need on
um
the use of money a situation like this
before and you probably covered this
remember when the DNC and Hillary
Clinton paid the law firm a million
dollars but and said that it was for
something else and we found out later it
wasn't it was wait a second Kevin that
doesn't sound like you're answering the
question about the Russia collusion it
wasn't for legal part and so they went
through
and they got investigated a million
dollars they spent and you know what at
the end of the day they didn't get
prosecuted they got fined Hillary's
campaign got fined eight thousand
dollars and
um the DNC got fined a hundred thousand
dollars even though they used a million
dollars
they knowingly hid the fact of what they
were doing to try to hide
um they got investigated so I look at it
from this perspective please we live in
America and it should be equal justice
um this was personal money
this one tried to hide this was seven
years ago statue of limitation and I
think in your heart of hearts you know
too that you think this is just
political and I think that's what the
rest of the country thinks and we're
kind of tired of that understand that
Kevin McCarthy gives a 90-second answer
or about a minute if it took 20 20 or so
seconds to ask the question he gives
about a minute answer
the question is about the looming arrest
and indictment of a president
and all he talks about is Hillary
Clinton you have to hand it to him he's
been trained pretty damn well deflect
deny and distract when it comes to
Donald Trump and his criminal actions
and the is it gaslighting a couple
people wrote to me and said David this
this is essentially gaslighting that's
that's what Kevin McCarthy is doing here
he's gaslighting the media well yeah
it's an attempt at gaslighting but it's
a very transparent one and I don't know
that this is going to work I don't know
that people are necessarily going to be
going for this and it's particularly
ironic that Kevin McCarthy says well we
want equal justice if it's one thing for
a republican then it's another thing for
a Democrat but you know that Kevin
McCarthy doesn't actually want equal
justice or at least his party doesn't
when it comes to actually trying to
create
equal situations where we say well the
rich and the poor are treated
differently by the justice system we
should equalize that now they don't they
don't actually care about that well
we're seeing dramatically different
outcomes
uh in all sorts of different measures of
attainment based on whether people live
by no fault of their own uh in poor
versus wealthy neighborhoods let's do
something about that now that sounds
like woke nonsense they want equality
when it's convenient for them and then
otherwise they go equality that's just
that woke nonsense that you guys won't
stop talking about so Kevin McCarthy it
took him a few days to be ready with the
talking points but it's all Hillary
Clinton all the time and we'll break
down I mean I I do think
I'm of two minds on the one hand if I
spend a lot of time myself talking about
how the Hillary Clinton situation he
references was very different I'm sort
they're kind of winning right because I
start talking about Hillary
at the same time it might be worth doing
a run-through of the Hillary Clinton
situation he's talking about and why it
is so dramatically different from what
Trump is embroiled in right now let me
know in the comments
should I do that segment about how the
Hillary situation is different or should
I ignore it all together because exactly
what they want is for people talking
about Hillary Clinton instead of Donald
Trump let me know in the comments and
I'm at your mercy whatever it is you
want me to do I will do we have a
voicemail number that you can call
absolutely anytime recently you may
remember that Lauren bobert the radical
republican congresswoman
um spoke very positively about the fact
that she's going to be a grandmother
despite only being 36 years old and
acted like this is a great thing the
Eggman and I by the way I told you all
the reasons why outcomes are way worse
when the younger mothers are
um the worse the outcomes are for the
kids in the United States in so many
different measures the Eggman called in
and he has a different perspective that
he believes is important to consider
hey Dave I'm calling about Lauren bobert
Taylor green whatever her name is the
one that's bragging about being a 36
year old grandparent
um Dave I know we're putting her down
for that and and it is deplorable but
Jews are like two percent of the whole
entire population not even actually way
less than that I feel like Jews don't
even have children till we're in our 30s
and we only have like one or two so do
you think that just the ideology of
being responsible parent taking care of
your children is going to make the Jews
and
um just smart liberals die out do you
think liberals need to just spread their
seed more and be less caring about
reproduction if you want to keep our
liberal moral agenda going or our Jewish
Heritage going for that matter
Shalom brother oh yeah have you ever
heard of a 36 year old Jewish
grandparents I'm 20 years older than her
and I'm not a grandparent yet so very
very that's very true and I I have a
nine month old so no there's a the
Eggman so the eggman's using a lot of
hyperbole among other things but he is
bringing up an interesting issue which
is the fact that Lauren bobert and in
many parts of the country among folks
like Lauren bobert
teen pregnancy is seen as a great thing
and abortion is seen as a bad thing it
leads to grandmothers in their 30s and
it leads to this hegemonic nature of
they are having so many more kids they
are more likely to end up being
right-wingers they are crowding out
liberal values and that is a concern I
mean when you it's true that the more
educated one is the later they they have
kids and the fewer kids they have it's
true that the wealthier one is on
average the more you wait to have kids
and you have fewer kids and it is also
the case
that I mean to talk about the Jewish
Community the Jewish Community is
overwhelmingly liberal it's arguably the
most liberal voting Block in the United
States other than black Americans and
it's right up there
um ultra-orthodox Jews have a ton of
kids much like Mormons do or Evangelical
Christians but that is a very small
percentage of of Jewish folks and so the
Eggman is not wrong in anything that he
is saying but
I don't know that bobert cheering being
a 36 year old grandmother makes me say
it's time to start having a whole bunch
of kids that that doesn't uh follow for
me but an interesting subject
nonetheless let me know your thoughts
we've got a great bonus show for you
today sign up at joinpakman.com you'll
get instant access I look forward to
seeing you there it's going to be a
great bonus show everybody but we'll be
back tomorrow otherwise
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the most
comfortable men's boxers and t-shirts
you'll ever find are at leisure of NYC
their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers feel as
light as air and their silky smooth
supima cotton crewneck t-shirts are
amazing I love them you'll get 15 off
with code Pacman at davidpackman.com NYC